[Musique]
mode
gilles babinet bonjour bonjour je vous
interview aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle singer view est
bienvenue j'aurais voulu avoir votre
avis sur l'existant digue data qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire
c'est un vaste sujet mais bon je pense
c'est avant tout une technologie sert
que c'est pas une religion et à ce titre
ça offre des opportunités fantastiques
mais aussi les menaces et des hors-jeu
de vie privée relativement important je
donne un exemple que moi me cher et je
pense qu'il résume assez bien le propos
c'est avec les big data je peux assez
facilement
réussir à prédire
l'état de santé
des gens à partir du moment où j'ai
donné j'ai des données en grand nombre
des données d'historicité de santé par
exemple de l'adn des choses comme ça la
question c'est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on organise ça est ce que on organise
ça de façon individuelle est ce que
l'organisme de façon collective à ce que
l'on organise de façon systématique
est-ce qu on le fait en mode opt-in
c'est un mode opt-in mode opt-in c'est
sur le consentement volontaire c'est à
dire que je dis je suis d'accord pour
que mes mes données de santé soient
traitées et à partir de là on pourrait
dire voilà on prévient les gens on leur
donne des conseils sur la façon dont ils
devraient faire
se soigner s'alimenter et c'est donc ça
c'est un rapport évidemment extrêmement
différent entre les institutions et les
individus parce que ça veut dire qu'on
accepte de confier des données
extrêmement sensible aux institutions
pour qu'elles puissent nous dira
question si vous faites pas ça dans six
mois dans un an dans deux ans vous allez
avoir une maladie grave coronarienne
deux chroniques de tous types donc de
même on pourrait très facilement dire
dans une population donnée c'est pas la
peine de vacciner tout le monde de la
grippe chaque hiver on peut repérer les
gens qui sont les plus sensibles et à
les inviter à aller se faire vacciner et
a contrario on peut aussi dire à
d'autres gens vous c'est pas la peine de
vous vacciner parce que j'ai une
sensibilité qui est faible à l'égard du
virus qui arrive donc ça c'est
typiquement l'enjeu des big data
mais on voit bien que le postulat
initial c'est la confiance s'il n'y a
pas de confiance dans le système de
santé
il ya des possibilités de déviance d'une
part et dans certaines de santé ou dans
les institutions là je parle à l'égard
de la santé mais c'est vrai pour tous
c'est à dire que
par exemple si je prends les transports
en commun ou les transports en général
on peut trouver l'utilisation des
transports en commun grâce à un but
atteint voilà on peut optimiser mais non
seulement les transports en commun mais
aussi mes déplacements personnels serre
que par exemple je pourrais avoir une
sorte de système qui va chercher dans
mon agenda et qui va repérer que je vais
au travail à telle heure et donc qui va
optimiser les horaires des bus en
fonction des intérêts collectifs c'est à
dire qui va dire olaya dans ce quartier
il ya 30 personnes qui vont être à telle
heure on modifie en temps réel entre
guillemets les horaires de bus parce
qu'on voit que c'est plus pertinents et
en l'occurrence ça ferait disparaître
les traces ici si vous deviez vous faire
l'avocat du diable et alors bon voilà
donc tout ça repose sur le principe de
confiance dans les systèmes et le
principe de juste réciprocité mais c'est
évident que
on peut avoir des glissements très
important c'est à dire qui est plus
réciprocité et que ça sert à abuser nous
donc l'exemple le gard la santé c'est
évidemment les assureurs donc les
assurances complémentaires et on se dit
ils refusaient d'assurer dès gens où ils
vont les assurés très cher et cetera et
cetera et ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas
de réciprocité puisqu'il ya un abus des
données qui sont utilisés au-delà de ce
qu'on veut il n'ya plus le sens de la
solidarité c'est à mon sens commun de la
répartition du système de santé fin à
l'utilisation du système de santé et
donc je crois que
les postulats qui préside à la mise en
place de big data sont efficaces c'est
une grande transparence démocratique et
un débat sur le modèle que l'on souhaite
parce que je pense que comme ces
systèmes n'ont pas été pensés ça
nécessite de se poser la question de
savoir comment on va les tuer vous font
part les débats est-ce que vous avez
suivi comment la programmation militaire
a été passé est ce que vous trouvez qu
en ce moment
ouais en musée j'ai trouvé que c'était
assez intéressant donc moi je me suis
insurgé contre l'article 13 versus 20 de
la loi de programmation militaire est en
fait seul effet je les fais pas ce que
j'ai compris finalement assez
tardivement
que
les
institutions ne comprennent pas ou en
tout cas ne veulent pas comprendre les
risques que les modèles institutionnels
quelques rais génère je m'explique
jusqu'à présent on considérait que les
écoutes ce genre de choses c'était
relativement
restreint sont des choses qui étaient
relativement restreint et qui était
cantonné à un aspect technique aux
techniques et donc on pouvait créer une
sorte d'entité qui allait être chargé de
faire ça et on a continué dans cette
direction et le problème que j'ai avec
les systèmes d'écouté que ceux rattachés
à l'exécutif et ils transmettent au
pouvoir judiciaire les résultats de l'
enquête mais de ce fait on biaise la
base même des principes démocratiques
qui sont la séparation des pouvoirs
et de fêtes l'esprit des lois et enfin
de monter ce qu en l'occurrence est
particulièrement maltraitées c'est dire
que je ne vois pas dans un modèle actuel
ce qui empêche pour ceux qui se
souviennent de sa une à refaire rainbow
warrior ou l'exécutif avait complètement
comment dire truquer les éléments des
enquêtes de se reproduire et de fait le
la notion de fonctionnement normal de la
démocratie être préservé parce que je
rappelle que les écoutes sont faites par
une institution militaire
sur requête ou non d'ailleurs du juge
est par ailleurs la police judiciaire
dont qui est chargée d'instruire les
enquêtes est rattachée évidemment
ministère de l'intérieur et donc n'est
pas indépendante non plus donc il ya un
vrai risque de
perversion trimestre du système je pense
que maintenant que nos vies sont
massivement numérique c'est à dire que
si je porte des objets connectés
ma vie réelle elle et elle est très
facilement monique rabin monitorat bhl
je pense que le il faut se reposer la
question de l'organisation de nos
institutions et y compris de
l'indépendance de la police judiciaire
parce que voilà moi je considère que les
les outils denquête numériques sont plus
faciles à à pervertir a truqué parce que
c'est virtuel et donc on peut introduire
des dossiers dans les ordinateurs des
gens
que la vraie vie que dans la vraie vie
parce que la vraie vie vous avez des
témoins vous avez des tierces parties
vous avez des preuves matérielles qui
reste ou pas et c'est relativement
différent je pense que
le législateur soit par ignorance
soit par mauvais esprits en treillis
mais a fait vraiment une erreur
préjudiciable au fonctionnement de la
justice et d'une façon plus générale de
la démocratie en mettant en place cet
article 13 20 et je crois qu'il est
encore temps de revenir là dessus
comment comment on fait à l'échelle du
citoyen pour repenser ses institutions
pour reprendre le contrôle de ses
institutions mais le c'est un vrai sujet
c'est même le sujet je pense c'est que
l'on se rend pas compte qu'on est en
train de changer d'air et moi je crois
qu'on passe de l'ère de la deuxième
révolution industrielle à l'unr de la
troisième révolution industrielle qui
est celle de la data et que ça pose des
problèmes éthiques fondamentaux et qui
nécessite un débat citoyen et ce débat
n'a pas lieu il a pas lieu parce que nos
institutions considère que c'est le
cours normal des choses l'évolution
normale des choses est d'ailleurs la
régulation qui nous est imposée qui est
mise en place par nos institutions c'est
une régulation qui est décalée parce que
elle continué elle continue à réguler
pro forma comme si on était toujours
dans une ère dans laquelle on est plus
et donc moi je crois que un c'est
essentiel que le monde politique soit
éduquée à ces enjeux là et puis au delà
de ça je pense que il ya un réveil
citoyen qui est indispensable et je
crois qu'on peut avoir un débat serein
sur ces enjeux je crois que c'est pas
manichéen c'est à dire que les
technologies permettent de faire des
choses intéressantes permettent aussi de
faire des choses négatives et qu' il
faut éviter que il ya une opposition
entre les pro et les contres mais que en
face la part des choses et concret un
environnement institutionnel qui nous
permettent de réussir cette transition
dans cette nouvelle ère lorsque vous
êtes sur conseil national du numérique
est ce que vous aviez l'impression
d'être écoutés
curieusement non j'ai pas eu le
sentiment d'être écoutés
jeu assez curieusement j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir une relative indépendance
il ya eu des choses sur lesquelles
ça c'est pas hyper bien passé je crois
que notamment on a eu la volonté d'avoir
une voix assez libre qu'est ce qui s'est
mal passé ce qui s'est mal passé à
plusieurs reprises on a exprimé un avis
très librement sans sens entre
guillemets passer par le canal officiel
et ça nous a été reproché ce que je peux
comprendre
et de fait comme je le raconte est dans
mon livre nous considérait qu il fallait
y mettre une sorte de guérilla positive
c'est-à-dire d'être dans le dialogue
mais en même temps d'afficher très
radicalement ce qui nous semblait être
une nouvelle voie radicale ou
franchement franchement franchement
c'est à dire de dire pas de pas mettre
deux d'entre 20 et de dire 'voilà ce
système fonctionne pas du tout et
d'ailleurs de mémoire je crois que le
premier ravi qu'on a envie c'était sur
une directive paquet télécom et sur des
enjeux de libertés publiques je suis pas
sûr mais je crois qu à peu près et ça
c'était le surlendemain de la création
du cnn ou dans la première semaine de la
création du cnn et sussex a un peu donné
le ton c'était assez drôle j'ouvre une
parenthèse parce que vous parlez de
télécoms qu'est ce qu'on pensait d'eux
des relations un petit peu incestueuses
entre orange et la dgse alors j'ai
entendu parler de ça objectivement je
voudrais pas dire de bêtises et pas
investiguer outre mesure ça si c'est
vrai c'est évidemment extrêmement
problématique
et
je connais pas bien le dossier ne
jouerait pas dire de bettina on ferme la
parenthèse
que mon petit le conseil national
numérique pour peser dans la balance
le conseil actuel bon il est un peu
nouveau donc je ne sais pas si je
pourrais mettre un avis
moi moi je pense qu'il faut avoir une
certaine radicalité c'est à dire que
on est face à des gens qui parce qu'ils
viennent d'une autre ère ne comprennent
pas bien les enjeux en question et ont
l'impression que c'est subsidiaire et
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut émettre
avec un certain à propos radicale
des avis il faut s'assurer
que
sa prise sur la société civile c'est à
dire que moi je rêve de concertation
très large sur les enjeux de data par
exemple je pense que les enjeux de data
sont extrêmement extrêmement
ambitieux en termes de potentiel
et que ça nécessite non pas
une réponse
immédiate mais une discussion permanente
sur tout un tas de sujets de société
par exemple est ce que on crève d
identité électronique et si oui dans
quelle mesure en garantie que ça va pas
être une source d'alu
quel est le le type de système de big
data qu'on peut envisager à sur
différents thèmes différents terrains
est-ce que l'éducation numérique doit
être
quelque chose de systématique et quels
types d'éducation en numérique etc etc
tout ça c'est un jeu qui sont importants
et moi je n'ai pas envie de les confier
exclusivement à des gens que je
considère être finalement les plus
soumis à la fracture numérique parce que
pour régulièrement parler avec des
hommes politiques mais aussi avec
différentes classes de la société c'est
là où je vois la plus grande fracture
numérique dire que les gens qui se font
imprimer leurs mails
c'est pas
des gens qui sont ouvriers en province
un peu comme les juges qui ont jugé à
faire un peu ton fameux incroyable avec
google est un petit peu si vous l'a su
acbc pour moi ça m'étonne pas c'est
juste le cours normal des institutions
donc des juges qui
n'ont pas été justes éduquer à ces
notions là
pourquoi parce que il ya un la classe
d'âge en général les gens qui sont à la
tête de ce pays bas ils sont plus vieux
que la moyenne des français d'ailleurs
les jeunes vont pas voter parce qu'ils
se sentent pas représentés et puis au
delà de ça il yal isolement
institutionnels dire que quand on
appartient à une institution d'état on
est un peu hors sol et de fait on voit
pas la vraie vie donc voilà on la voit
moins qu'ailleurs et donc effectivement
on assiste à des conséquences et je
trouve que c'est plutôt intéressant
cette affaire bluetooth c'est à dire que
là ça montre vraiment de façon
extrêmement concrète ce qui se passe et
que moi lorsque je le dis on me dit mais
là tu exagères c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe et c'est ben si ça se passe
partout comme ça dans l'état ils ne
comprennent pas ces gens je du tout vous
avez déclaré dans une interview que la
cnil a était un ennemi la nation
oui et je pense que j'ai pas été
forcément bien compris par tout le monde
lorsque j'ai dit ça mon propos c'était
de dire que c'est exactement ce que je
viens de dire c'est que je vois pas
pourquoi la cnil confisquerait le débat
à l'égard de la donner en disant voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on va la réguler pour
moi le problème la cnil c'est que ils
n'ont cessé de dire ouais tout ça c'est
très dangereux et moi je crois qu'à la
fin le message que je percevais c'est le
mieux pour que ça arrive pas c'est qu'il
y en ait pas et je pense que
les gens n'aient pas ok mieux je digère
diversifiée oui mais c'est parce que dit
la cnil s'est en tout cas il ya
plusieurs cnil il ya la cnhi je pense
avant cette déclaration est depuis une
évolution dans le déballe dans la lnah
le prise de position de la cnil là
dessus mais encore une fois le problème
de la cnhi c'est le cantonnement au sein
d'une institution administrative d'un
débat qui est un débat qui nous concerne
tous et je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
laisser la cnil ou par ailleurs la haute
autorité de santé
sid et la façon dont nos données doit
être doit être traité moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que personnellement je
préfère que mes données soient plus
largement utilisée mais que j'ai une
plus grande transparence sur la
compréhension des enjeux la façon dont
elles sont utilisées et une plus grande
capacité à pouvoir décider ou non par
exemple c'est un sacré objectifs du
groupe c'est un sacré objectif à l'heure
actuelle on est dans l'air pratiquement
de la perte de confiance généralisée
sans tomber dans la théorie
conspirationniste ou contestataire ou
actionnaires les journalistes ne sont
plus écoutés les hommes politiques ont
perdu
la confiance de leurs électeurs le vote
contestataire se manifeste à travers le
vote du front national semble même je
dirais que des gens votent front
national sans même adhérer à leurs idées
uniquement pour vendre la terre là on
touche à un débat qui est très très
sensible à votre avis quel est
l'organisme ou la l'évolution des
consciences qui pourrait apporter
cela le rétablissement de cette
confiance dans la gestion de données le
big data c'est quelque chose qu'ils
peuvent très salutaire pour l'évolution
d'une société mais qui peut être aussi
très long feu assure que sur 2 qu'est ce
qu'on fait c est un débat est ce qu'on
fait a fondé ce que voulait être le fer
de lance pour fédérer 7 7 couvert la
confiance autour de big data si vous
êtes prêt à tendre la main des hackers
tendre la main à des gens un petit peu
moins représentatif mais beaucoup plus
proche de la population alors c'est le
coeur du réacteur ce dont on parle pour
répondre à la première partie de la
question c'est moi je crois que une des
raisons qui font que ce pays a pas
confiance dans ses institutions
c'est la nature même de ces institutions
qui sont nés au monarchique c'est
extrêmement verticaliser on est le pays
au monde où il ya plus d'élus et à 600
mille élus en france six cent trente
mille élus c'est unique au monde
rapporté à par habitant cela fait un élu
pour 100 habitants et de fait on fait ça
moi ma conviction c'est pour priver
l'expression de la société civile direct
sa démocratie directe voilà c'est
l'enfermement du débat au sein de
spécialistes et on est associés d'une
société qui est fasciné par l'élitisme
par l'élite par les élites et je
constate que dans beaucoup de pays ont
fait évoluer le cadre institutionnel
pour inclure la société civile dans le
débat et on est très loin de faire ça en
france je pense c'est même un peu la
terreur des institutions sire que moi je
crois que c'est par peur des jacqueries
donc de province que on a créé les
institutions qui ont cette forme là et
il me semble que à une époque où les
institutions perdu pied par rapport à
cette nouvelle donne technologique
on doit soit leur imposer de changer de
forme soit créé le débat à côté ainsi
sur écran si oui comment
mais je pense en leur montrant qu' ils
ne comprennent pas donc c'est pour ça
que moi j'ai souvent des mots assez durs
à l'égard du pouvoir politique parce que
je considère qu'ils mettent le pays dans
le mur et que au delà de ça il favorise
l'émergence de pensée radicale notamment
du front national de ce genre de choses
parce que ça fait trente ou quarante ans
que ils nous imposent
une alternance de débats entre la droite
et la gauche qui ne sont pas la solution
c'est en gros c'est
bah c est ce qu on fait une société de
l'offre une société de la demande je
pense qu'il va à l'ère du numérique
c'est plus l'enjeu c'est plus l'enjeu
par exemple les enjeux de la gratuité du
travail gratuit de d'avoir des
plateformes open c'est absolument pas au
coeur du débat politique et ça devient
tellement
significatif je rappelle que le bureau
statistique américain a dit maintenant
la croissance américaine ya les chiffres
qu'on peut mesurer de façon monétaire
mais il ya aussi une part de travail et
gratuit quand on accède à wikipédia on
accède à la richesse mais on paye pas
pour ça et donc ça cette notion là elle
peut paraître l'intelligence
collaborative way l'intelligence
collaborative exactement ces notions là
ces notions là moi je pense qu'elles
devraient faire partie des débats
politiques elle s en faut absolument pas
partie mais pas seulement la démocratie
directe c'est aussi un enjeu de débat
politique et je pense que ils vont
continuer à avoir un effritement de leur
confiance tant qu'ils prendront pas en
compte la dimension de la société
numérique qui est à des fondements qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce que l'on
connaît actuellement donc pour répondre
à la question
je pense que oui le problème c'est qu'il
ya pas ce débat qu'il faut ce débat oui
moi je m'applique pour le faire émerger
et j'essaye de trouver des plateformes
avec que
différentes institutions différentes
associations réfléchir à ça j'étais
encore en train encore ce matin et hier
d'envoyer des mails à ce propos je sais
pas exactement comment ça peut se faire
et oui évidemment toutes les bonnes
volontés sont bienvenues
présenter je voudrais votre avis sur les
hackers
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors je
connais pas bien loin des hackers je
rencontre évidemment mais il n'y a pas
de labellisation officielle des hackers
moi je jeu il ya plusieurs choses dans
on va dire ce que m'évoque la notion de
hackers pour moi il ya la notion de la
pensée alternative qui
intéressante parce que c'est rompre la
pensée commune et dire on peut faire les
choses de façon différente
ça c'est évidemment quelque chose que je
suis
que je respecte beaucoup il ya le
principe du contre-pouvoir est
évidemment dans une période actuelle où
finalement on a des choses qui sont
chouchoutés qui sont pas exprimés à voir
ce contre-pouvoir c'est bien et je suis
vivant très favorable à ça et je pense
que les hackers doivent aussi émettre
des idées donc pas uniquement être dans
les notions de codes et de choses qui
sont pas forcément comprise par le grand
public mais va participer au débat
public puis il ya la troisième notion
c'est la coeur un peu noir évidemment
moi je peux pas adhérer à des gens qui
ont des comportements aux minorités semi
daichi qui sont évidemment une minorité
je le pense aussi en général
30 question vous avez reçu le titre de
19 champions est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un petit peu ridicule pourquoi pas
plus pourquoi pas un gîte à six coeurs
ou digital superstar j'adorerais digital
super héros ça m'irait très bien et je
veux bien mettre une cape si quasi asie
bruxelles change le titre
d'accor en deux dernières questions à
gilles babinet donné aussi possible aux
jeunes générations qui nous écoute sur
internet d'honneur des conseils des
préconisations qui si vous aviez laissé
une bouteille à la mer sur internet
l'immortalité ce conseil qu'est-ce que
vous laisseriez à ces générations
alors il ya plusieurs types de conseil
et conseils façon à l'égard de la vie
professionnelle genre de choses donc
moi je bon c'est idiot de le dire mais
je pense que
le fait maîtriser un peu le code
c'est bien mais ça mérite d'être dit
même si je suis pas forcément devant les
gens qui sont
les plus à même de faire attention à ce
conseil puisqu'ils sont déjà là dedans
je je je pense que la pensée alternative
c'est important c'est à dire que on est
dans un monde qui privilégie la pensée
unique plus que jamais et a dès qu'on
commence à sortir du cadre on est plus
grands cadres donc je prendrais aucun
respect pour
ce que je dis assez souvent c'est que
dans les années 60 on a eu une floraison
de philosophes et de pensée alternative
et c'était une époque où on pouvait pas
faire l'utopie et aujourd'hui on est
dans une révolution
conceptuelle technologique qui mené par
le monde du numérique et que on voit pas
de pensée alternative pas beaucoup et
donc je crois que c'est important de
l'exprimer et la troisième chose que je
dirai à la jeunesse c n'attendez pas
qu'on vous donne le pouvoir prenez le
père qu'il faut bien comprendre que
partout les gens qui détiennent le
pouvoir ne vous le donnerons pas ils
vont garder et le gardon de façon
illégitime et ça moi je le vois partout
tout le temps et ce qui est très bizarre
d'ailleurs c'est que par exemple aux
deux jours j'étais dans un journal et on
disait
voilà vous faites partie de la jeune
génération j'ai 47 ans je veux aussi les
accès coup ça montre bien combien il ya
un décalage serre que en gros les gens
qui sont pouvoir en 60 ans la génération
montante à plus de 40 ans et le reste
c'est des mineurs perpétuelle donc on
peut pas laisser les choses continuer
comme ça
j'imagine et merci
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
l'idée de la commission trilatérale
vient de david rockefeller il ya 35 ans
il a réuni
où quelques dizaines d'européens
d'américains d'eau japonais en leur
disant écoutez on a des problèmes en
commun par exemple
les relations des classes chine par
exemple les
relations avec ce qui était à l'époque
l'urss
essayons d'avoir des positions communes
qu'ils soient dans l'intérêt général
on est dans la captation de données le
recueil de données dit la loi c'est à
dire qu'on va chercher chez des
prestataires chez les intermédiaires
techniques on va chercher des données
tout donné ça peut être des courriers
électroniques des courriels et des
courriers électroniques ça peut être des
données bancaires ça peut être des mots
parce c'est tout ça qu'il s'agit demain
on s'est arrêté permanent et j'étais
super de voir que l'éducation ce qu on
n'était pas sensibilisé à st
oui steve carell on peut très bien
basculer une seule vers un régime
beaucoup moins démocratique avec des
valeurs moser
l'actualité récemment a montré encore
une fois pour pas si les knicks à ce qui
me fait penser tout ce que nous leurs
la cour a été utilisée légitimement par
justement ces gouvernants pratique il
veut quoi les pouvoirs et mac automatisé
gêne aussi mon automatique des
arrestations en masse et c'est ça qui me
fait peur tant qu'il est le seul état
démocratique de faire bien bien faire
confiance à nos écrans
[Musique]